le discours avant le discours sur ça
aurait pu être grave
heureusement ça n'est qu'une gifle mais
n'est pas un discours table c'est c'est
un discours qui ne me qui ne n'est pas à
la hauteur de la gravité de cet acte
alors justement rigolo ggg la réaction
du président de la république manuel ma
conduite qu'a tenu à relativiser les
choses puisqu'il a dit tout va bien il
faut le relativiser cet incident qui est
je pense un fait isolé
il ne faut pas que cela viennent
occulter le reste des sujets si
important que concerne la vie de
beaucoup il faut respecter les fonctions
dans la république et je ne lâcherai
jamais ce combat les fonctions quelles
qu'elles soient sont plus grandes que
nous et ne doivent pas faire l'objet
d'agressions particulière donc on voit
qu emmanuel macron et c'est un voile à
calmer le jeu est divisé les choses de
relativiser les choses justes de risque
quoi sur ce risque trois ans de prison
et 45000 euros et qui plongera pas sa
peine au succès relativement peu nancy
la présidence porte plainte oui est ce
que vous pensez comme les terrains non
la présidence ne va pas porter plainte
devant rien ah oui le hockey est ce que
vous êtes pour que la présidence porte
plainte justement vous qui le verrait
obligé je pense que le préfet va porter
plainte
c'est un violent sur des airs de
l'autorité publique pour moi c'est très
grave donc oui fauqué plainte pour
mettre un terme à cette escalade
possible de la violence pour eagle au on
le voit vous c'est ce que voit mais il
faut que je marque ou s'ils voulaient
d'abord très intéressant d'avoir la
réaction du président de la république
mais franchement je ne vous en tant que
citoyen je mentionne dans ce cas présent
je m'en fiche je veux dire la fonction
n'appartiennent pas celui qu'il occupe
et là c'est la fonction qui a été qui a
été attaquée c'est une violence
symbolique mais terrible pour une
société
alors peut dire ça n'est qu'une gifle
non ça n'est pas qu'une gypse et c'est
ça que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on a
franchi une limite la limite ultime
c'est à dire que dès maintenant il ya
pire +2
il n'y a plus aucune limite à
l'agression contre l'autorité plus
aucune chasse est d'accord il ya plus de
sacré c'est la violence symbolique là
elle est terrible pour la société toute
entière dans les institutions pour le
pays voilà c'est pas et le fait qu'ils
n'étaient que gifle et qu' ils soient
pas blessés que lui-même c'est le geste
voilà c mais ce geste il en livre c'est
une transgression qui quittent est
encore une fois pour la société il ya
plus d'ordre social
si le président de la république
et l'autorité de toutes les autorités et
qui est qui a pourtant un mandat du
mandat du peuple à rien c'est une
élection au suffrage universel et il
incarne le pays paye soula sous la
monarchie comme canto faisait une petite
entaille au roi ça a été le cas de
damien dernier régicide l'ancien régime
qui avait entaillé un peu le bleu le
bras 2015 il a été roué en place
publique écartelée mais quoi ça du tout
pas voilà parce que on atteignait en
porter atteinte aux symboles de
l'autorité à ce sur quoi reposait la
société le jour où on a commencé à
emprisonner le roi louis c'est de la non
seulement la monarchie disparu mais la
société belle qualité s'est effondré il
a fallu transférer la souveraineté sur
autre chose sanglant
on